but first many young people see social
media stardom as a fast track to Fame
and Fortune people you've never heard of
can become very famous and very wealthy
very quickly from the business of
bagging clicks and followers online but
with more than 500 hours of content
uploaded every single minute just to
YouTube how do they even begin to get
noticed well some influencers have a
talent they can sing or dance some give
Brash opinions some play computer games
some give friendly tutorials on things
like how to do makeup or make music but
others get their clicks by honestly
behaving like complete morons in
California a YouTuber and pilot faced 20
years in jail for crashing an airplane
to get more subscribers others have
jumped from City buildings taking on
wild animals crash cars you name it have
a mad at it if someone has tried it just
for the clicks an order in the name of
becoming insta-famous this week of
social media prankster named mizzy has
generated headlines and abject outrage
for so-called pranks which mostly
involve just terrorizing innocent
bystanders
[Music]
we're gonna die
hey yo
what does public anger grew this week
London's met police announced they were
looking for mizzy real name bakari
bronzagaro the lord caught up with him
yes and today it was fine 365 pounds and
given a criminal Behavior order which is
supposed to ban him from posting to
social media without the written
permission of the people in his videos
you might think that's not much of a
punishment or much of a deterrent what
does he think well fresh from the
courtroom he's here now all right well
good evening to you hello hello peers
long time no see it's been a long time
no see last time I caught on your thing
with my friend
that's right you're paid in the
background
okay well I'm not your mate um what I am
is an interviewer I'm curious about what
has been motivating you to terrorize the
people around where you live I wouldn't
really quit at terrorizing I'll just
call it more having fun but let's get
this out of the way first I apologize
you see this situation that blew up on
the Internet they're walking into random
houses
the next day I apologized to the woman
because I felt bad in it like deep in
her social media like it went deeper and
social media that's why I didn't record
it she recorded me apologizing to her I
told her sorry and she explained that
she was terrified because like children
were in the house and I understood what
are you doing in the house
was a dean in the house I don't know it
was a stupid video like I got peer
pressure to say I don't want to say it
like in that way but for somebody else
is full I'm not I don't blame you know
no one else when you're breaking that
house with it with a with a woman and a
husband for my own accord no I'm just
saying okay you went through their door
right but it's not your house you're not
supposed to be in there oh no you are
causing a lot of alarm to that poor
woman and to her children who are in the
house you then terrorize this poor
elderly woman and take a dog away and
traumatize her the story about that hang
on
let me speak no no no no no no I'm going
to tell you let me talk about it for the
viewers no no wait a minute wait a
minute for the viewers wait a minute for
the viewers who don't know what you've
done I'm going to tell them so you hold
on me right now no you can hold on right
now I'm explaining everything I'm
explaining you know what's been
happening don't just keep talking like
an idiot right right don't let me finish
what the viewers don't know you did I
you go up and you do these things you
take your dog from an elderly woman you
LeapFrog over the top of an Orthodox
Jewish man standing at the side of the
road minding his own business you go up
to women in the street and say do you
want to die it wasn't a woman it was a
man and she there were also women there
but I only say it to the man right you
shouldn't be saying it to anybody fair
enough why are you why in the name of
so-called prankster humor why cause so
much alarm and distress to so many
people do you get your kicks out of
doing that not necessarily but you could
say that this whole public outro just
makes me laugh because people are
getting hurt over something that didn't
happen to them and that's how I see us
what do you mean people are getting hurt
over something that didn't happen to
them everyone acts like they have this
Persona like they don't care Oh social
media is a facilities than the other but
when me comes out and does the Mad thing
everyone has something it's the Mad
thing you know you already just you
already said it was the matter no it's
not mad it's moronic it's the kind of
thing anybody could do and you do it for
kicks and you do it for clicks and you
get your little moment on Tick Tock and
presumably your peer group that you
referenced earlier they all say good on
you good on you missy this is hilarious
meanwhile some poor woman thinks he's
stolen her dog and is traumatized
another woman has her two kids and
you're bursting into their house
Uninvited all right you're jumping on
Jewish people
there's people hold up a wait a minute
you did cool it was a Jewish person cool
but there was a trend going around a
tick tock with three oh oh I've been
listening to numerous people black
people white people age any types of
people I don't discriminate so don't
stop saying Orthodox Jewish person like
I only targeted him and it's only him
that I went for why are you targeting
anybody in that what would you mean why
am I targeting anyone it was a trend it
was a trend I just done it for a trend
what's the trend what's the trend free
or oh jump over someone at the time of
the beat however much you scare them
however much you scared or even if you
push them into a car no that's that that
didn't happen though because I saw it
didn't happen but it didn't happen but
it didn't happen a lot of the stuff that
you do could have consequences far more
serious but you don't care do you as
long as you get a lot I have remorse I
have remorseful ladies
are you there for my parents have you
been there what's your life tell me you
tell me my life presumably presumably
you're about life you assuming you're
about to tell me the sob story what's
the sub story hold on then what's your
story about what's so bad about your
life in it I I just do it for fun on or
off camera I do my take tell me about
your life what justifies this what's
happened to you that makes you think
you're justified in doing this what do
you tell me about my life well you said
you said you know anything about your
life tell me about yourself because I'm
trying to get into you because I'm black
because I guarantee you because you're
black yeah I guarantee if I don't give a
damn about your skin color really no who
cares why would you care of what color
your skin is I just think you're an
idiot oh thank you I think you're idiot
too that's fine you're perfectly
entitled to yeah the show's called
uncensored I think you're an idiot for
what you've been doing I also think
you're an idiot for playing the race car
when no one's mentioned your skin color
really again you don't have to mention
it to her I don't care about your skin
color hey I care about the fact that
you've been terrorizing all these people
for a sustained period of time I also
care about the fact you've only got a
tiny fine today no deterrent to you
whatsoever you don't show any real
remorse you don't really care you can
lose all week simple as the UK laws are
weak simple as and that's not my fault
that's not my fault like what's your fan
what's your family make of what you've
been doing
what did my family meet well I don't
chat to my mum anymore and why not why
not because I just don't talk to us
irrelevant to you but I just don't chat
to her in it and what else my sisters
are calm but like obviously they don't
fully comment what I do but do any of
your family condemn what you do no of
course not like obviously they think
it's all perfectly normal no there's
certain videos that they'll be like no
you can't be doing that like especially
just walking into the random house is
one certainly not but that was more of a
spur of the moment thing I've got egg
done and my ego got a hold of me and I
realized that at that moment and that's
why I went to apologize the next day
after this who blew up out of proportion
and I felt like bad personally I don't
think you felt okay well you I think you
felt bad
you're talking I'm talking I'm talking
I'm talking I'm talking I'm talking it's
fine I'm talking carry on being an idiot
okay okay we are standing districts
every time I'm actually not going to
call you missy it's obviously a stage
I'll call you bakari bronze right all
right bukhari bronze let's try and talk
to each other as human beings all right
yeah I'm trying to understand
why there's no real remorse here
what do you mean there's a consequences
I want to apologize or social media I
could have recorded that apology and
that would have been another viral video
whether it's hate or whatever literally
hate brings money hate brings lacks
hates brings views it doesn't matter
level hate it still brings views why
would why do you prefer to do the
hateful stuff it's not like I prefer to
the hateful stuff it's just like it's
easier to do the hateful what are you
laughing obviously I don't think it's
fun but you're a funny person you do
think it's funny you're a funny person
you do I've seen the videos you do you
think it's just really fun at the time I
think it's funny my fan base thinks it's
funny and it's we outside in it it's a
movement but what's something deep down
what's the move deep down being free I'm
not letting anyone tell you nothing
that's why I can do all of this stuff I
have I'm the most hated person on the
internet right now I've done it who you
are okay then whatever you say in it
whatever you say most people watches
will have never heard of you oh now they
are that you just put it to me
they'll just look at the way you're
behaving now and I think yeah he's a
complete [__] all right and you're a
compete
mobile interrupted me when I'm trying to
talk because you keep talking in this
animated manner trying to stop asking
you any questions
and then you say is it because I'm black
is it somehow
why are you going back to that I said
that once
if you were white I'd have exactly the
same view about your moronic Behavior
All right but I'm curious who in your
family is there to tell you this why do
you need to go to my family I'm my own
personal talk about me because
you don't talk about me not my family
yes but here's the problem what's the
problem you are clearly a product of
your upbringing no I'm not I'm my own
person I've always been my own person
you've had no one to tell you this is
wrong of course people have told me it's
wrong family friends everyone's told me
who soldiers what do you mean my own
mother told me this wrong there's been
situations between me on my way right so
your mother doesn't like what you're
doing yeah
so why don't you stop doing it because
my mother told me to stop doing
something okay you listen to your mother
you listen to somebody else I'm my own
person I'm I'm legally I don't know so I
can do I what are you gonna do now what
am I going to do now
Twitter all Missy is banned and I'm
gonna be on Twitch yeah I'm gonna start
streaming on Twitch IRL streams gaming
streams my twitch is busy as live if you
want to get that but yeah I do want to
try and come up with a sincere apology
or not no I don't need to come up with
no sincere apology I already have my own
remorse and I already I already what do
you mean okay then whatever you it's all
a bit of a joke and if you steal some
old woman's dog it's all a bit of fun if
you jump on a Jewish man it's all a bit
of fun if you run into people's houses
with young kids and terrorizers it's all
a bit of fun but what I'm saying is
nothing really massive what I'm saying
to you is there's been plans to change
up everything can you you let us know
jalapeno you just talk your own thing
you have your own set morals and yeah so
that's you no it's not about morality
okay cool cool
still talking I'm still talking
interrupting again again
why'd you keep interrupting let me tell
you we're gonna put both of ourselves
out of this misery and we'll just end it
there because you should end as I said
at the start you're just a complete
[__]
foreign